regardez dans les yeux vous pensez aux
derniers chiffres de votre carte bleue
alors attention je vais essayer à 99% je
pense que c'est ça non mais c est non si
c'est le bon code de guillaume genton
[Musique]
salut juste avant que la vidéo commence
une bonne nouvelle pour vous c'est un
concours qui permet de gagner tout ce
que vous voyez là
alors comment participer comment gagner
ça et bien simplement en vous abonnant
mon magazine curieuse pour la deuxième
année on lance ce concours là pour fêter
la deuxième année c'est du 18 janvier au
16 février il n'y a rien d'autre à faire
que s'abonner et là vous vous dites oui
mais moi je me suis abonnée au mois de
novembre du coup alors sachez que toutes
les personnes qui se sont abonnés
curieuse après le 17 novembre participe
déjà automatiquement au concours comme
ça il n'y a pas de c'est pas injuste tu
vois voilà je vous mets le lien dans la
description comme ça si vous connaissez
pas le magazine vous le découvrez on va
sur notre deuxième année on a mis des
jolis lots j'espère que ça vous plaira
tirage au sort le 16 février et
maintenant on passe à la vidéo que ce
soit aussi le but
[Musique]
salut bienvenue dans cette première
vidéo analyse de 2021 et elle va
ressembler un peu la première analyse
que j'étais sur la chaîne à savoir que
j'ai fait sur la chaîne à ça j'ai du mal
avec ce cod qui va n'importe où à savoir
je vais analyser eux moi parce que c'est
ce qui revient je crois le plus dans les
commentaires des analyses de quand est
ce que tu t'es analyse toi-même bfm
analysé mois sur une émission de télé on
avait fait quand il y avait eu un
médecin appelé où c'était cette vidéo là
et bien là on va le faire quand je vais
sur le plateau du moins quand j'étais
sur le plateau de thé pmp donc c'était
un petit peu avant le 22 novembre le 22
novembre j'ai fait un spectacle one shot
en ligne en streaming spectacle
interactif et donc ima vérité pour
paraître spectacle du mentalisme en
général etc
j'avais répondu ok à l'invitation
maintenant on va voir un petit peu ce
qu'on peut analyser au milieu de tout ça
sur mon comportement ma manière d'être
ma manière d'agir de parler de réfléchir
on entend ça ou pas puisque l alarme
parce que tu crois que c'est parce que
je vais craquer pour droit d'auteur qui
le détecte al avance donc en guest est
partie de la vidéo est un peu longue
elle fait 27 minutes
donc on va s'écrouler dedans pouvoir
aussi les moments intéressants il ya
grosso modo deux phases la phase ils
vont simuler un entretien d'embauché je
dois donner mon avis sur la manière de
faire de demander une augmentation ce
genre de choses sur les chroniqueurs et
la deuxième phase si on m'a demandé de
faire du mentalisme sur l'un des
chroniqueurs pris au hasard par cyril
qui devait me demander un truc simple et
qui s'échauffaient en mode
vas-y trouve son numéro de carte bleue
mais vous verrez c'est avec moi des
spectacles complets un énorme carton et
avant tout pour ceux qui n'y connaissent
rien en voulais vous montrer la tête que
je fais c'est parce que j'ai vu moi même
la photo de moi qu'ils ont envoyée et ça
c'est un vrai truc je sais pas pourquoi
on tient à disposition des photos de
presse récente ils vont toujours cherché
sur google images les plus vieilles
photos du monde qui existe ce qu'est le
mentalisme qui est favori car et je vais
prendre dans un instant votre carte
bleue
oui parce que vous êtes le jeu penche le
de quoi donc faut savoir que cyril
hanouna germe les émissions comme il
veut c'est à dire que s'ils se chauffe
sur une idée qu'elle n'est pas prévu ben
faut suivre
alors après c'est une règle tacite c'est
à dire que si t'es pas d'accord avec ça
faut pas y aller quoi
ça se mettre dans le bon état d'esprit
avant d'aller négocier c'est à dire on
arrive devant son patron déjà on et
comment on est on est on est heureux
mais pas encore de vrai c'est comme
avant de rentrer là sur un plateau de
télé ou dans la vie quand vous allez
voir quelqu'un vous mettez dans l'état
d'esprit de je vais bien tout va bien
faut il vaque un peu le stress est aussi
se rappeler pourquoi on mérite un peu
plus de salaire il faut avoir les
arguments à la ba oui je vois exactement
ce que je fais donc clairement j'ai un
petit stress parce que je suis pas dans
mon environnement naturel du tout et on
peut voir je parle les deux tiers du
temps à cyril hanouna et un tiers du
temps j'essaye de choper au regard le
reste des chroniqueurs parce que je
pense que mon état d'esprit à ce moment
là c'est si ça le soul ce que je dis il
va me virer et c'est pas très
divertissant moi ce que je raconte j'ai
pas en train de faire des grosses
blagues et doux et en même temps il faut
que le reste des chroniqueurs adhèrent à
ce que je fais pour que pour que ça se
passe bien et que j'ai le temps aussi de
m'exprimer
donc on le voit je fixe deux tiers du
temps et quand je vois qu'il est
accrochée je repasse sur les
chroniqueurs et après je reviens sur lui
quand j'ai peur qu'il ait décroché c'est
pas devant la personne la personne n'a
pas forcément envie de négocier le
salaire à ce moment la maison elle
aurait déjà eu ce petit coup d'oeil donc
il faut savourer ce qu'est née sa valeur
et pourquoi on mérite plus d'argent
qu'il ya six mois en arrière aucun ans
en arrière
il faut être préparé à un refus pour
pouvoir négocier le nom et dire ok alors
non pourquoi aujourd'hui
ok si on règle pourquoi est ce que dans
six mois on peut s'engager par écrit
là je veux qu en train de le perdre donc
en fait il faut tout visualiser comme ça
à la vente et le dernier truc
oui je jette les coups d'oeil et là on
voit sur l'écran de partager que lui
fait des oui oui avec des petits
mouvements donc ça s'est un peu de
nervosité et bien de regarder au-dessus
gbi donc qu'il est en train de décrocher
et là où j'ai fait pause on voit
vraiment que je suis en train d'analyser
ça sur lui donc à j'analyse moi qui est
en train d'analyser à l'ina et je me dis
ok il faut absolument que je boucle et
juin redonne la main sinon ça valse ou
les imams coupé alors justement chacun
votre tour vous allez vous tourner vers
moi et me demander si sa part s était
fendu plus quoi
et voilà je pense avoir ma place sur ce
plateau et voila j'aimerais voir et vous
aussi vous pouvez faire quelque chose
pour moi fabien et b ça partait pas mal
il ya la presse aparté pas bien parce
que vous avez déjà tour ont fermé
misés en dix ans une petite augmentation
je pense que je vais faire pause mais là
je suis un jeune bien à l'aise peut-être
un peu trop mauvaise mais en gros c'est
parce que là pour le coup je re bascule
dans mon univers on me demande de faire
quelque chose que je sais faire que
j'adore faire donc on voit mon menton il
est parallèle le seul chu ni un
sentiment de supériorité ennemis en
train de m'écraser pareil pour le reste
du corps je suis pas complètement ouvert
en mode jeu prend toute la place
mais je suis pas non plus refermée comme
ça donc j'ai juste à mon aise et je
pense qu'en fait comme on me demande de
faire cet exercice là bas c'est ce que
je sais faire dans ma vie et donc je
vous dis complètement que c'est sur une
émission de télé en ce moment on détecte
un mensonge pas bien pour nos
téléspectateurs comment ils font pour
détecter un mensonge alors bon on sait
jamais à 100% si une personne ment ou
pas il ya pas un être humain une machine
qui peut le faire par exemple quelqu'un
qui raconte une anecdote en vous
regardant toujours dans les yeux
eh ben c'est pas bon chic l'âge et
récupérer du stress voix j'ai une petite
accélération de la voix même si je
récupère les codes de tout à l'heure en
fait je récupère du stress parce que je
sais que quand il pose des questions
comme ça j'ai compris qu'il aimerait que
je dise bah en fait les to 4 points à
savoir c'est ça ça ça et ça mais en fait
c'est jamais aussi simple dupuis vous
voyez que je parle beaucoup quand je
parle donc je suis obligé mois de
détailler un petit peu et je sais que je
marche sur le fil de me faire éjecter et
de perdre mon temps de plateau à ce
moment là que quand une anecdote et
montrer clairement que les détails
inutiles les détails c'est des primaires
en parlant évidemment il y avait des
bouchons enfin il y avait des bouchons
d'abord je voulais prendre le bus mais
c'est le bus était pas là et le dernier
truc est très cool c'est si vous avez un
doute à l'afrique mla le feu jeudi est
le dernier truc en le regardant dans les
yeux
c'est vraiment pour envoyer un mail ou
pas regarde j'ai presque fini
alors vous demander à la personne de
raconter l'anecdote à l'envers et adam
jeudi la vente était au sénat lui quand
même pour les faits de le poser ça c'est
déjà dur à faire qu'on dit la vérité
alors non c'est impossible et là c'est
quand on va passer directement
maintenant au moment où le faire du
mentalisme parce que là c'est un petit
peu long les moments tu parles je
raconte des trucs que vous avez déjà
donc ce n'était pas ça qui était prévu
je savais que cyril à aller me lancer
sur un chroniqueur mais je ne savais pas
qu'il allait me pousser à ce point et
vous allez voir que n'a pas été si
simple est qu'il ya un rebondissement de
ouf et là
je veux voir ma tête au moment où ça va
être très difficile pari que capable de
deviner le code de carte bleue d'une
personne maintenant on le voit
directement à mon visage que c'est en
mode
ok c'était ce qu'il veut le ton sur ton
pied pour dix ans d'horreur qui vient
d'une grande famille je vois bien comme
ça dans le dressage actions macarthur
allez donc moi vous pouvez me dire pour
y trouver son code de carte bleue je
peux essayer de le faire je prenais en
fait je grossis lâcheté de ma part il
veut donc là vous pouvez trouver le
numéro de carte bleue jeudi je peux
essayer de le faire je promets rien
d'ailleurs je me protège mais en même
temps je ne sais pas comment ça peut se
passer avec lui et ce qui va jouer le
jeu
j'ai aucune idée
pour moi c'est un peu trop en plus
indirecte oui c'est ça j'ai un doute
vous précisez joué le jeu mentalement
alors on rend le mentalist c'est pas
rentrer dans la tête des gens allaient
voler des informations ces parcelles de
bio aujourd'hui je minimise mes
compétences
à partir du moment où la personne veut
jouer le jeu est ce que ça vous dérange
d'enlever vos lunettes bio mais des
choix bien vous une collation la
perruque de partir elle sera tournée
magique que pour vous je disparais que
pour vous les autres vont encore vous me
regarder dans les yeux vous pensez le
derniers chiffres de votre carte bleue
je vais énumérer les chiffres de 0 à 9
quand vardin caudan oui du code de la
carte bleue donc vous prenez deux
derniers chiffres du code de la carte
bleue cancan j'énumère les chiffres
quand vous entendez le vôtre vous vous
dites stop mentalement je précise
mentalement avec la bouche ça met
beaucoup trop donc je ne remonte pas osé
me regarder dans les yeux ça peut être 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0123 ok c'est pas mal
on voit quand même que ils jouent le jeu
parce qu'ils jouent le jeu en tant que
chroniqueur de l'émission mais watts
il me prend pas du tout au sérieux par
contre même ne serait-ce que dans son
attitude et sa manière de faire par
contre ce qui est très cool c'est que
ici toutes les indications parce qu'on
l'a la caméra en plus on a eu les yeux
au deuxième coup que j'ai prononcé de
est ce que c'est bien d'eux oui oui ok
on n'est pas trop mal
le code ces dossiers bon je vais pas
verbalisé à cette dernière et autres je
les écris ray
on se mettra d'accord pour voir si c'est
bon pas mais moi j'ai une machine à
celle où je me dis mais non vous avez vu
comment jonathan faut que je me mette
dessus regardez comment je le regarde je
vais j'y vais vraiment c'est comme ça
que vouloir qu'on essaie il va vouloir
essayer de faire un règlement juste là
je dis mais en fait on va jusqu'où dans
le numéro et on voit aussi mis à vous en
tant qu est pas très rassuré du goût
j'aurais dû chercher le premier le
premier je peux avoir une réaction du
concours rapide si je comprends comment
on fonctionne et c'est alors 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 0 harry potter en danger votre
milo c'est pas mal moi je pense que
c'est 8 et 9 août je vais essayer
d'avoir le deuxième ou le troisième vous
vous prenez un des deux dans votre tête
et vous me dites pas lequel comme ça ça
augmente la difficulté pour moi mais
c'est vous qui allez dire 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 12 et coule à 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
vous avez vu comment ça fait 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 et oui en fait on a là vous
étiez pas magique le mentalisme dans ces
moments là on entend vraiment la montée
ça redescende donc on est sur sept et on
va faire une dernière fois pour le
troisième là je me rends pas encore
compte que je suis en train de dire tous
les numéros à l'oral
un numéro de carte bleue je dois pas le
dire en direct à la télévision
je suis en train de dire votre code de
carte bleue je viens de me rendre compte
exactement ce que j'adore je ne dirais
pas le dernier que vous n'avez pas pris
vous regarder dans les yeux ça peut être
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ok je pense que je
les ai alors là vous allez voir le
désespoir sur la tête de fabien
milliards de kilowatts crête chez les
1000 euros de débit je l ai vraiment
même les rendre et on les donnera une
association oui avec plaisir
j'ai pas l'air aussi stressé que ce que
je pense mais intérieurement quand même
je le suis un peu plus c'est à dire que
je suis je suis un can qui se construit
au fur et à mesure et c'est un pro là
avec autant de monde on me demande autre
chose à faire c'est pas assez juge pas à
mon ex complet alors attention je vais
je suis là je suis stressé de est ce que
c'est le bon code outils chez le bon
code degrés aujourd'hui on perd les 1000
euros mais j'ai vraiment mis millions
c'est vrai je confirme que sa marge est
costaud mais reina
ah non merde tout vient en fait ce qui
se passe quoi en fait j'ai deux cartes
bleues c'est le club de mon autre carte
est arrivé là c'est vrai j'ai une autre
carte dans la poche en test match j'ai
essayé de garder visage impassible mais
on voit à quel point j'ai été choqué
quand ça a fait côte faut gérer leurs
maîtres j'étais pas prêt à enfin j'étais
pas précis parce que j'avais peur mais
regardez ma tête en fait je reste
beaucoup trop longtemps
comme si je ne croyais pas geste
qu'autre chose là je vérifie pour voir
s'il a bien tapé ce que j'ai écrit et
j'ai un petit sourire de façade mais on
voit même la mâchoire comment s'écrit ce
pays si nous pouvions pas ce qui se
passe en fait j'ai deux cartes bleues
celles de mon autre carte est donc là si
vous avez pas compris
c'était en gros il a sorti une carte
bleue moi j'ai dit penser au numéro deux
au code de votre carte
il a pensé aux codes d'une autre carte
donc forcément la carte qu'il a sorti le
code qu'il est en train de penser c'est
pas le bon s'est pas associée mais moi
ce que je me dis là c'est pas chouette
en fait tout va bien c'est que je me dis
donc si la sarre fait code faux sur ce
deuxième coup sûr rebondissements qui ça
fait code faux parce qu'à un moment
donné j'ai pensé que c'était 7 alors que
c'était si ce cas une micro erreur mon
passage et les catastrophiques j'en veux
dire c'est bon c'est cote faut tout le
temps c'est nul ce qui fait ils
chercheront pas à comprendre en fait le
il y avait juste une petite erreur donc
c'est pas mon avantage ce qui se passe
là ça marche a gardé les mains jointes
jamais vous me voyez comme ça jamais
jamais je vous parlais souvent aussi de
des variations en fait je ne touche pas
beaucoup de visages depuis de mission
envoyée et là ce que de faire des choses
comme ça de me toucher les mains de
rentrer en contact avec moi même c'est
un gros signe de stress
c'est la deuxième carte alors attention
je me demande quel patron quand du coup
comme c'est la deuxième on mai 2000
attention j'ai marqué je m'aime ils ont
été vraiment mille sebhaoui je viens de
me mordre la lèvre là est vraiment c'est
parce que je suis dans ce stress de 6 la
ccot faut une deuxième fois parce que
j'ai fait une petite erreur ce qui peut
arriver
en fait je peux pas être pardonné parce
qu'il ya déjà eu le code faut avant
alors que c'était juste un problème de
logistique il a pas pensé au code de la
carte qu'il a donné au regard des îlots
voiture vraiment en contrôle en cours
attention je refais le même code si
c'est le bon c'est énorme
si c'est le belge achète moi même une
place pour mon spectacle de dimanche
réussit quand même à faire ma promo au
milieu au cas où la regarder c'est
peut-être que j'aime et c'est stressman
quoi et j'ai les mains de poser pour me
contrôler un petit peu con pour
l'instant des poteaux rizières
m
et là je suis dans le soulagement plus
complet bien je retourne s'asseoir
direct alors qu'il m'a pas forcément
demandé mais parce que j'ai un
relâchement quand même de tension il
faut que je m'assieds pour reprendre un
petit peu le contrôle sur moi pour ceux
qui se poseraient la question c'est 1000
euros ont vraiment donc été débités et
en grossir et là nous l'a proposé soit
s'il en a les moyens de le verser une
association soit en fait de le
rembourser et c'est l'émission de prod2
cyril qui versait quand même cet argent
à l'association voix c'est un
relâchement pour un fou au départ il
m'avait dit ce sera sûrement sur maxime
guennic tu feras quelque chose je pense
que la cites doit être content que ce
soit pas lui ben voilà on s'arrête là
après une demande de sortir du plateau
et to buy avait pas une énorme analyse
affaire fait ce qu'on voyait bien que
j'étais un peu pris par le stress du
direct au départ après pris par le
stress de ce qui m'a été proposé de
faire comme ça après ben il ya eu les
rares de cartes et alors là je crois que
je me suis jamais vu aussi stressé sur
un plateau télé c'était un exercice
super difficile et vous avez vu par
rapport à l'autre analyse que je vous
mettrai à la fin de la vidéo avec le
médecin comme il ya beaucoup de
chroniqueurs
j'ai pas beaucoup de place à prendre
donc je suis pas en mode auto promo
comme j'avais fait le choix et c'est le
moment il me demande de partir du
plateau on ne voit pas ça c'est rohff
en fait il propose de rester tout le
long de l'émission juste pour écouter en
tant que chroniqueur quoi inviter ou si
je préfère partir et j'ai demandé à
partir à ce moment là parce que j'avais
trop peur que dans l'émission il me
lance un challenge et sur un truc encore
plus compliqué et je me suis il vaut
mieux dans ce moment là quand tu as fait
un truc est nickel partir là dessus
plutôt que de rester bien toulon pour
bien se planter derrière voilà c'est une
règle de vie je veux mais l'appliqué
assez régulièrement à chaque fois que ce
sera nécessaire
j'espère que ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à la chaîne n'est pas
bonne et je m'appelle fabien olicard
toujours wen tong et activer la cloche
pour voir les autres vidéos donc laïque
et la vidéo si elle vous a plu dites moi
ce que vous avez pensé vous votre
analyse dans les commentaires de mon
état de stress est ce qu'ils se voyaient
ce qui se voyait pas j'irai lire tout ça
et puis moi je vous dis ah
à bientôt prenez soin de vous ciao